[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat en étant
centre pour 90 minutes tous les soirs du
lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h et voici le
sommet de ce 16 mars faute de marées
fiable à l'Assemblée nationale pour
adopter la réforme des retraites
Elisabeth borne déclenche l'article 49-3
de la Constitution la première ministre
le gouvernement mais aussi Emmanuel
Macron sorte affaibli de ces trois mois
de bras de fer Marine Le Pen réclame la
démission de la locataire de Matignon
elle a annoncé elle-même qu'elle accepté
d'être le fusible banco qu'elle saute le
gouvernement peut-il être renversé le
rassemblement national peut-il tirer un
profit électoral à long terme de cette
séquence politique et puis le mouvement
social qui faiblissait est-il rebooster
par l'absence de vote à l'assemblée on
répond à ces questions entre autres dans
une minute et puis pour notre second
débat volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour je vous propose un
gros plan sur ces nouvelles menaces
venues d'IR de son programme nucléaire
le 28 février dernier l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
décelait des taux de particules
d'uranium en Russie 18 fois supérieur à
la limite autorisée pourquoi et
s'inquiétant quel lien avec le soutien
de l'Iran à la Russie dans le conflit en
Ukraine et puis la révolte populaire
dont on ne parle plus ou presque
a-t-elle été étouffée beaucoup de thèmes
passionnants à aborder dans trois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord donc le récit de
cette folle journée parlementaire malgré
le vote favorable du Sénat ce matin le
président de la République n'a pas pris
le risque de présenter sa réforme à
l'Assemblée Fabien Ricard
c'est le scénario que le gouvernement
voulait éviter dans un hémicycle
surchauffé Elisabeth borne se présente
devant les députés peu après 15 heures
l'exécutif passe en force sur la réforme
des retraites
peux pas prendre le risque de voir 175
heures de débat parlementaire
s'effondrer aussi sur le fondement de
l'article de 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 le 49 3
synonymes d'adoption sans vote de la
réforme à la sortie de l'hémicycle la
nupes crit au coup de force démocratique
la première ministre en annonçant le
49-3 vient de finir d'humilier de
bafouer le le Parlement une bonne fois
pour toute ce gouvernement cette
première ministre n'est pas digne de
notre démocratie n'est pas digne de la
République aujourd'hui commence le
premier jour du reste du quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron de la fin du
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
jusqu'au bout le gouvernement aura
compte et ses voix mais le compromis Noé
avec la droite ne permet pas à la
macronie de s'assurer une majorité les
députés modem alliés de la majorité
présidentielle ne cache pas leur
amertume et blâme les républicains on
est très mécontent du 49-3 on sait
pourquoi le gouvernement est obligé de
le faire par l'irresponsabilité totale
du groupe LR qui n'a pas su assumer ses
choix des choix qu'il porte depuis plus
de 15 ans aujourd'hui c'est juste
inadmissible de nous faire porter le
chapeau alors qu'au sein même de leur
groupe Renaissance horizon modem il y
avait des défaillances et donc il faut
d'abord se mêler de ses propres affaires
avant de venir chercher des poux dans
les parties d'opposition après cette
adoption les oppositions se tournent
vers l'émotion de censure qui devrait se
multiplier
il se gouvernement
vont être déposés et je pense qu'elles
seront relativement nombreuses le
gouvernement sera resté sourd à l'ultime
coup de pression de l'Inter syndicale
qui s'était réuni devant l'Assemblée
nationale à la mi-journée un peu plus
tôt au Sénat l'adoption du texte avait
été sans surprise une simple formalité
grâce aux voix de la majorité de droite
et du centre la gauche assume avoir tout
fait pour empêcher le texte d'aboutir
oui vous poussez jusque dans vos
retranchements et si nous voulions faire
ça c'est parce que nous accompagnons le
mouvement social et ces millions de
salariés qui ne veulent pas du report de
l'âge de la retraite à droite on se
félicite d'avoir imprimé sa marque au
projet de loi du gouvernement mais après
les aternoiements des députés LR Bruno
retailleux reconnaît une fracture au
sein de sa famille politique je ne le
comprends pas d'un point de vue
politique qu'est-ce qui fait l'honneur
de la politique c'est la constance c'est
une ligne politique comment comprendre
que alors que depuis des années et des
mois encore ont soutenait une réforme
qui portait à 65 ans au lendemain d'une
journée de manifestation qui a mobilisé
1,7 millions de personnes selon le
ministère de l'Intérieur les syndicats
appellent à intensifier le mouvement
social et j'accueille tout de suite mes
invités à Charlène bézina bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes
constitutionnaliste Frank Morel bonsoir
bienvenue à vos questions chez Flichy
Grangé ancien conseiller social de
d'Édouard Philippe et expert emploi à
l'Institut Montaigne Stéphane zumsteï
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes directeur du département
Opinion à l'institut de sondage
ipso c'est Jacqueline Mathilde sirop
bonsoir Mathilde politique bienvenue à
vous Anne Charlène bézina bon voilà il y
a le la première ministre le président
d'ailleurs plus la décision du précédent
n'a pas pris le risque du vote qu'est-ce
que vous retenez vous de cette journée
tiens je commence comme ça est-ce qu'il
y a une image une déclaration ou un
sentiment général que vous retenez de
cette journée un sentiment d'échec
finalement un sentiment de défaillance à
tous les étages on a un parlement
affaibli un gouvernement affaibli un
peuple dans la rue ce soir donc oui
l'image d'une journée de cristallisation
de de tout ce que cette réforme des
retraites avait porté comme tension au
climax finalement aujourd'hui je retiens
aussi cette Marseillaise à l'assemblée
qui ne discontinue pas une première
ministre qui qui n'arrive même pas à
marteler son discours donc certes
l'usage du 49-3 existe sous la Cinquième
République mais ce 49,3 là on s'en
souviendra euh il a évidemment quelque
chose de de tout à fait marquant eu
égard notamment au fait que jusqu'au
dernier moment le gouvernement pouvait
jouer une autre stratégie donc il y a
aussi peut-être une erreur de de choix à
ce moment-là puisque choisir le 49-3
aujourd'hui c'est d'ores et déjà avoir
un échec de la de la négociation avec
les LR qui finalement sait jouer
jusqu'au dernier moment donc il y a
quelque chose d'un peu gênant là-dedans
j'ajoute aussi que j'ai été un peu
brusqué par la phrase du président de la
République vous avez dit c'est en effet
bien sûr le président de la République a
plus l'habitude de choisir les 49-3 que
le premier ministre mais c'est une
décision profondément personnelle du
Premier ministre puisqu'il engage sa
personne son nom et entendre de la
bouche du Président je vous autorise à
recourir au 49-3 c'est quand même
toujours un petit peu sucré salé pour le
texte de la Constitution
cette déclaration du président sur nos
confrères Agence France Presse qui c'est
issu des débats lors du conseil des
ministres extraordinaire qui est
convoqué justement pour autoriser le le
je suis en train d'essayer de retrouver
à la citation elle est quelque part sur
une de mes nombreuses fiches mon intérêt
politique et ma volonté politique était
d'aller au vote parmi vous tous je ne
suis pas celui qui risque sa place ou
son siège ça effectivement bon ce petit
rappel du président mais je considère
quand l'État les risques financier
économique sont trop grands en y
reviendra sur la stratégie des maladies
Macron un peu plus tard mais je trouvais
intéressants effectivement d'appuyer vos
propos par cette citation Franck Morel
on peut pas dire autre chose que un
gouvernement une première ministre un
ministre du Travail peut-être même
jusqu'à un Emmanuel Macron affaibli ce
soir bien évidemment bien évidemment
parce que le choix stratégique qui avait
été fait dès l'origine vous vous l'avez
dit ça avait été via le fait de choisir
l'option 64 ans plus accélération de
Touraine plutôt que l'option 65 ans dès
la présentation de la réforme de jouer
la carte du compromis avec elle et donc
cette carte du compromis avec LR avait
même été même allé très loin puisque le
gouvernement avait brûlé toutes ces
cartouches entre guillemets dès le début
de la séquence en intégrant dans le
projet dès l'origine un certain nombre
de revendications qui étaient celles de
LR et notamment de LR au Sénat
d'ailleurs puisque régulièrement étaient
voté par le Sénat la réforme qui est
très proche de celle que le Sénat a voté
tout à l'heure et donc à partir de là
effectivement le tunnel qui a été celui
du parcours parlementaire assez
mouvementé que l'on que l'on a pu
constater ne se termine pas par un vote
classique en comptant précisément sur ce
compromis qui avait été fait avec Heller
mais par un 49-3 et donc on peut pas
s'empêcher de se dire à l'issue de ce
parcours parlementaire et de ce 49-3
mais finalement est-ce que le projet
Nord est pas pu être différent et par
exemple est un projet qui table sur 65
ans avec au fil du mouvement social un
certain nombre de concessions sur les
carrières longues qui auraient pu être
dégainées et avec un équilibre financier
Infiné qui aurait été différent de celui
dans lequel on se trouve c'est à dire on
a l'impression un peu d'une séquence
perdant perdant c'est à dire parce que
finalement
l'intérêt enfin l'équilibre financier il
va pas être il va pas en sortir avec le
gouvernement qui a lâché toute une série
de concessions dans le cadre de la
discussion parlementaire et des
concessions qui étaient plus des
concessions d'ailleurs en direction des
parlementaires et singulièrement des
parlementaires LR plus que des
concessions dans le cadre classique
social et à l'arrivée on se dit bah oui
finalement on a une réforme sur laquelle
on va dire entre 30 et 50% des économies
générées sont mangés sont consommés par
les différentes concessions qui ont été
faites et on se dit bah que le plus
difficile dans tout ça c'est que sans
doute dans 5 à 7 ans il faudra en mettre
le couvert il faudra recommencer ces
faits les Français on sait assez stable
d'ailleurs étonnamment stable ils sont
majoritairement hostiles à la réforme il
y a aussi une stabilité sur l'espèce de
de fatalisme en disant de toute façon
elle passera on verra si ça évolue dans
les prochains jours mais le 49-3 il a
mauvaise presse dans l'opinion française
ça l'était déjà avant ça va être
renforcé ce soit donc ça va d'après vous
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer ça va
renforcer ce sentiment cette hostilité à
la réforme on a souvent entendu ces
derniers jours ces dernières semaines
que les Français étaient résignés non
ils sont pas résignés c'est pas vrai
effectivement ils ont toujours fait le
pronostic quoi qu'il arrive le
gouvernement finirait par passer son
texte on voit que les choses ont bien
plus compliquées que pour le
gouvernement que les Français ne le
pensaient il y a encore quelques jours
mais ils sont pas résignés ils ont
soutenu vous le disiez et de façon
remarquablement stable tout au long de
de cette étape de de ces débats et de
finalement de cette guerre de l'opinion
et ils ont soutenu les les mouvements
les organisations syndicales les
éventuelles blocages et nous disent
toujours que si on devait aller faire
encore plus de blocages vers une
radicalisation pour l'instant il
soutiendrait ses mesures parce que c'est
toujours la même chose c'était la même
chose en 1995 quand il y a des blocages
qui est considéré comme responsable de
ces blocages par l'opinion publique
aujourd'hui c'est très clairement non
c'est pas les griffes c'est pas des gens
qui vont bloquer les raffineries
éventuellement ce sont pas les
contrôleurs de train qui ne vont pas qui
vont empêcher les trains de fonctionner
non c'est l'obstination le gouvernement
et c'est le terme qu'on a beaucoup
employé mais qui à mon avis résume tout
c'est la supposée brutalité du
gouvernement et du président de la
République ce que les Français n'ont pas
accepté n'ont pas toléré donc vous
pensez que là le fait qu'il y ait eu
149-3 déclenché aujourd'hui peut changer
les choses du point de vue de l'opinion
est-ce que le soutien
à l'opposition peut davantage se
renforcer qu'est-ce que ça peut changer
comme ligne
certains de ce qui va se passer dans les
jours qui viennent mais cette opposition
cette hostilité au projet de réforme a
déjà et déjà un niveau très haut des
deux tiers des Français c'est beaucoup
c'est pas 740 c'est deux tiers des
Français depuis 3 mois sont hostiles
c'est aussi est-ce que ça peut profiter
aux oppositions politiques c'est ça aux
parties de léopathie pour l'instant
forcément pas forcément et d'ailleurs je
ne pense pas quand on voit le spectacle
auquel on a pu assister il y a quelques
semaines à l'Assemblée nationale les
Français très clairement ont condamné ce
genre de méthode là je ne pense pas que
la France insoumise sorte renforcée de
ce qui s'est passé il y a quelques temps
le gouvernement évidemment le principal
perdant même s'il arrive même si
l'émotions censure n'aboutissent pas et
encore c'est pas persuadé c'est pas sûr
mais tout le monde a perdu la nuit pêche
a perdu les LR ont énormément perdu
évidemment qu'elle des aveux pour
ericsiotti pour Olivier Marley mais quel
désaveu fraîchement fraîchement élu et
assez brillamment président de président
des républicains il est incapable de
tenir ses frondeurs alors et le RN c'est
toujours la question à chaque fois on
voit bien compte tenu de
l'institutionnalisation de la campagne
de
d'institutionnalisation du RN on se dit
toujours c'est le RN qui va en profiter
il y a aucun marqueur qui ne montre mais
c'est vrai que en tout cas il ne sort
pas le RN affaibli de ce qui s'est passé
alors que tout le monde à côté sort
affaibli alors moi ça tombe bien parce
qu'on a on a un peu brossé les
différents chapitres à reprendre en
disant mais c'est très bien en détail
dans dans ce débat j'aurais posé une
question un peu plus générale sur l'état
de santé de notre démocratie
Erwan Balan le et puis alors il y a
aussi toutes les lignes de fracture
interne et Erwan Balan qui est député
MoDem disait tout à l'heure c'est une
c'était une erreur de d'utiliser ce 49
toi de faire vu l'état de notre
démocratie est-ce qu'on doit parler de
crise politique français
est un outil constitutionnel qui a été
utilisé à plusieurs reprises dans
certaines périodes on parle de la de la
période de Michel Rocard ou Michel
Rocard était premier ministre et où il y
existait une majorité relative il a été
utilisé je crois sous votre contrôle à
28 reprises donc je parlerai pas de
crise politique ou de crise sociale ou
institutionnelle ce qui est certain en
revanche c'est que le caractère apaisé
de notre démocratie ne s'est pas
améliorer c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire et on a pu le mesurer à travers les
débats qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis
par exemple la dernière grande réforme
des retraites parce que il faut se
rappeler que la réforme des retraites de
2010 ça avait été un hydroz non plus il
y avait eu 14 manifestations il y avait
des débats assez musclés je me souviens
par exemple que le président de
l'Assemblée avait été poursuivi par les
députés de l'opposition avec des grands
cris donc c'était déjà quelque chose de
d'assez costaud on va dire et c'était
pas pour pourtant une crise politique
mais pour autant ça s'était d'abord pas
terminé par un 49,3 alors il est vrai
que la configuration de l'assemblée
était différente de ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et puis on avait réussi
somme toute à passer à ces rapidement à
autre chose puisque par exemple l'année
d'après il y avait eu une réforme de la
formation professionnelle qui avait été
adoptée ce qui s'est passé depuis c'est
que depuis on a eu les gilets jaunes on
a eu le mouvement des gilets jaunes on a
une un regard par rapport aux politiques
en général qui est encore plus
distancier de la part de nos concitoyens
et puis on a une majorité relative qui
n'existait pas à l'époque et donc le
cumul de l'ensemble de ces circonstances
fait que le contexte est beaucoup plus
compliqué alors de là à parler de crise
ça voudrait dire que tout ça est
insurmontable et que on a plus qu'à
rentrer chez nous et que c'est terminé
non rien n'est insurmontable mais ça va
prendre du temps ça va rendre du temps
et ça va prendre des efforts ça va
nécessiter des efforts votre avis
là-dessus unchaine désina peut-être
essoufflé essoufflement de la Cinquième
République en tout cas je vais peut-être
prendre un petit peu le contrepoint
parce que je rejoins
bon des 49-3 on en a eu on a on l'a déjà
dit à partir du moment où il y a une
opposition entre la rue et le Parlement
c'est pas pour autant une crise
politique néanmoins ce qui pourrait moi
me convaincre de l'idée d'employer ce
terme de crise politique et je suis je
suis pas certaine d'ailleurs que crise
signifie absence de solution bien au
contraire la crise est souvent le creux
de la vague qui peut amener à un nouveau
message moi ce qui pourrait me
convaincre de d'employer ce terme de
crise politique c'est l'ampleur aussi de
de ce gap qui se crée entre la
démocratie parlementaire et ça
représentation finalement et vous l'avez
dit les gilets jaunes n'ont pas aidé à
ça notamment et j'ajoute que la majorité
relative a été à mon avis très
sous-estimé par rapport à sa difficulté
politique par rapport à son aridité
sociale et je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous
vivons le premier échec de de cet esprit
d'absence de synthèse possible dans une
assemblée fracturée et nous avions la
gageure en juin d'avoir une assemblée
beaucoup plus représentative que toutes
celles de la cinquième rép aussi réunis
et pour autant cette représentation
sociale nous n'avons pas su au niveau
parlementaire quelque chose donc ça ne
plaît pas pour plus de profondionnelle
ça ne plaît pas pour l'idée d'un contrat
de majorité dont on n'avait parlé et la
majorité de projets sur laquelle
d'ailleurs Emmanuel pas du tout Emmanuel
Macron Elizabeth borne vous voyez les
lapsus de la Cinquième République ils
nous vont faire mais Elisabeth borne l'a
dit dans son discours de 49-3 elle a
fait le rappel exact des termes de son
discours d'investiture et ça n'est pas
anodin elle a dit je me suis engagée sur
des majorités projets on voit bien
aujourd'hui que ça va être beaucoup plus
difficile les images de cette journée
qui resteront forcément il y a la montée
d'Élisabeth borne à la tribune de
l'Assemblée sous les hués des députés de
la nups on revoit cette séquence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ce qui est écrit sur les panneaux
si vous étiez en train de nous poser 64
64 ans c'est non voilà et puis ensuite
la Marseillaise va dur il y aura une
interruption de séance
décidée par Yelle pendant quelques
minutes de 3 minutes Steven il y a
quelque chose que moi j'ai un peu de mal
à comprendre dans la stratégie de la
nups pour l'instant enfin depuis deux
mois
ça leur profite pas dans les en tout cas
dans les sondages
pourquoi continuer enfin je pose une
question volontairement un peu basique
quoi pourquoi continuer parce que
l'objectif politique électoral de la
nups c'est de et surtout de la France
insoumise évidemment c'est de consolider
son socle électoral bien sûr que le
spectacle auquel on a pu assister à des
plus à la majorité des Français ils
n'ont pas compris pourquoi il y avait ce
spectacle aussi à que parfois ce sont
des employés en revanche quand vous
interrogez les sympathisants de la
gauche radicale les gens qui vraiment ne
votent pas mais votre France insoumise
aime Mélenchon aime les différents
porte-parole de sa formation politique
eux ils sont absolument favorables à ce
type d'agitation c'est ce qu'ils
attendent le terme ins qui a été très
bien trouvé pour pour définir leur
partie c'est vraiment ça ces gens-là
s'inscrivent dans l'insoumission pas
dans la révolution pas dans la révolte
pas dans l'insubordination mais malgré
tout c'est ce qu'ils attendent de leur
leader et certes la majorité des
Français n'approuve pas ce genre
d'attitude mais peu importe quelque part
est-ce que la colère parce qu'on peut
vraiment employer le terme de colère de
des leaders syndicaux alors là je
reviens au fait que les débats soient
pas aller au moins jusqu'à l'article 7
enfin les 64 ans à l'Assemblée on l'a
entendu fit Martinez lamberger est-ce
que ça ça n'impacte pas même le cœur
électoral de de LFI nous parce que ces
gens-là sont en révolte le thème mais
peut-être exagéré mais pas pas tant que
ça en révolte contre le système on
parlait tout à l'heure de de cet écart
de ce fosser qui se creuse entre les
entre les Français et leurs élites
politiques il y a des électeurs qui sont
beaucoup plus sensibles à cette à cette
à ce divorce quelque part il y a
l'électorat évidemment de la droite
radicale du rassemblement national mais
quand vous interrogez quand vous rentrez
vraiment dans le vif du sujet notamment
dans des enquêtes qualitatives avec des
militants de la France insoumise ça très
très loin c'est et la méthode Mélenchon
si on l'appelle comme ça elle est
totalement approuvée c'est ce qu'il faut
faire c'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
faire rendre aux gorge à ce gouvernement
et le faire retirer son projet et donc
c'est totalement assumé de la part des
de la France insoumise et je ne suis pas
persuadé que ce soit un mauvais calcul à
long terme là encore dans une optique
d'une éventuelle dissolution dans les
mois qui viennent ils ont un et toi
captif qui ne se retrouvent dans aucune
autre force politique et dernière chose
là-dessus sur ce point c'est que il y a
une bataille des classes populaires qui
a été totalement perdu par tout le monde
par la droite il y a longtemps mais
aussi par la France insoumise c'est pas
c'est pas les ouvriers c'est pas les
gens dès classement social ou qui
cherchent des emplois ou les pauvres qui
votent pour la France insoumise c'est ce
sont les banlieues et aussi une partie
des milieux aisés des grandes
agglomérations françaises il y a aussi
cette idée cette volonté de récupérer
une partie des milieux populaires qui se
sont égayés soit dans l'abstention soit
dans le vote en faveur du rassemblement
national alors on va continuer de parler
de la nuque je vous propose un extrait
du discours de la première ministre
quand elle vise justement les parties
enfin l'Alliance de gauche à l'Assemblée
je n'ai pas envie de revenir non plus
sur le comportement de ceux qui ont tout
fait pour bloquer le débat qui ont
refusé d'échanger idée contre idée
programme contre programme et ce sont
contentés de multiplier les insultes les
excès et les attaques et les cris au
moment même où je m'exprime dans son cul
preuve supplémentaire
ce sont les mêmes qui n'ont cessé de
remettre en cause notre procédure
parlementaire nos institutions et donc
notre démocratie
la nupette qui parle de déni de
démocratie et finalement c'est aussi ce
que renvoi Elizabeth borne à ses
opposants qui fait du mal à la
démocratie alors
ce comportement ou plus le gouvernement
en utilisant le 43 dans un contexte
comme celui-là même si on rappelle les
uns les autres que c'est parfaitement
légal c'est dans la Constitution et ça
déjà été utilisé
rejoint votre enfin la tension que vous
que vous matérialisez dans cette
question c'est que en tant que
constitutionnaliste j'aurais du mal à
dire que tout ce qui est dans la
Constitution n'est pas démocratique en
soit la Constitution a été choisie par
le peuple et on y reviendra pas
néanmoins
l'accumulation de l'usage de tout les
outils de ce qu'on appelle le
parlementarisme rationalisé c'est-à-dire
d'outils quand même relativement
autoritaire assumé par attention pas
uniquement la France beaucoup de régimes
parlementaires pour discipliner les
majorités a quand même tendance à
brusquer le débat et ici on a eu déjà le
choix d'un véhicule législatif très
contestable qui est celui de du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificatif qui a pour seul
avantage d'accélérer le débat et de
permettre l'usage de 49-3 donc on voit
bien qu'on était d'ores et déjà dans un
dialogue qui allait se passer sous la
menace de de la brutalité et ce qui est
intéressant de voir aussi c'est que la
Constitution est descendue dans la rue
aujourd'hui l'article
49.39-3 a acquis une popularité qui est
à mon avis le synonyme de la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron vous savez qu'on a
parlé du de cette question du jupitérien
de l'unilatéralité de cette méthode et
peut-être même à tort ou à raison je
pense peut-être à tort parce que
l'article 49-3 est d'usage démocratique
et il faut le redire en période de
majorité courte il est important de
pouvoir compter ses voix et il sera
important que le 49-3 redevienne à
nouveau légitime dans dans l'Assemblée
nationale mais aujourd'hui il incarne
cette méthode brutale un mot Mathilde
et ensuite je vous donne la parole
d'échec là de la majorité relative
continue de la situation dans laquelle
on est comment est-ce que là le
gouvernement peut ou pas rebondir avec
les moyens les outils dont il disposent
constitutionnellement
l'histoire que la parole se distribue un
peu sur le 49-3 parce que j'ai souvenu à
la fin du quinquennat de François
Hollande sur la loi Macron de 2015 et
sur la loi el khomri en 2016 de pancarte
dans les manifestations avec
dénonçant le 49-3 ou l'usage du 49-3
donc c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau
non plus d'avoir d'un côté l'usage du
49-3 et une situation de mouvement
social par rapport à une réforme c'est
quelque chose qui a déjà été mis en
exergue les deux concomitamment cette
violence et avec ce niveau de
communication j'en suis passionné encore
une fois c'est vraiment nouveau de de
ces dernières années quand on pense à
Michel Rocard qui l'a utilisé et il est
vrai qu'en revanche il y a vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs il y a le 47 2
c'est-à-dire il y a l'usage des
dispositions spécifiques au texte de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
permettent d'aller plus vite pour pour
simplifier et qui a qui ont abouti au
fait qu'il n'y a pas eu de vote même en
49-3 à l'Assemblée lors du premier
passage mais effectivement l'addition
des deux renvoie quelque chose d'assez
je reprends la question de Mathilde
parce que qui est quand même importante
comment faire maintenant c'est à dire
que si avec un 49-3 presque démonétisé
ça et une majorité et des députés LR sur
lesquels on peut pas construire le texte
en question le parcours du texte il est
terminé pour l'instant le prochain point
de vigilance il va être de nature
constitutionnelle parce que l'addition
du 47 2 avec les débats autour de
l'usage du 47 2 pour un texte
rectificatif c'est-à-dire pas un projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale d'une part plus le 49-3 on sait
très bien que le Conseil constitutionnel
ne fait pas que du droit
prend aussi en considération un ensemble
d'éléments d'ambiance on va dire dans le
cadre de l'examen Intex donc le prochain
point de vigilance il va être là après
la question que vous soulevez à mon avis
elle a surtout un intérêt pour ce qui va
se passer sur d'autres textes après
c'est à dire la difficulté qui va être
celle du gouvernement par exemple sur la
loi le projet de loi immigration avec la
gauche qu'il trouve trop à droite et la
droite qu'il trouve trop à gauche pour
pour simplifier
et donc avec le fait qu'il sera
extrêmement compliqué d'avoir une
majorité d'adhésion et même une majorité
je dirais de briquet de broc un peu ça
sera un petit peu compliqué l'usage du
49-3 qui est plafonné pour les textes
non financiers à 1 par session donc qui
effectivement va rendre les choses
extrêmement compliquées alors justement
on a évoqué le Conseil constitutionnel
on va parler maintenant avec cam avec
Tam traduit des recours bonsoir Tam
bonsoir bienvenue heure de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau quel recours
pour les opposants à cette réforme des
retraites écoutez la première arme c'est
la motion de censure et cette arme et
bien elle est déjà dégainée à trois
motions sont annoncées le rassemblement
national en dépose une la France
insoumise en dépose une aussi ainsi que
le petit groupe liotte ce groupe
centriste qui en envisage une c'est le
groupe qui pourrait rassembler le plus
de voix et ils ont dit aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont déposeraient une si le
gouvernement ne démissionne pas et si il
n'y a pas de retrait de la réforme je
rappelle qu'il doit y avoir 48 heures
entre le dépôt et la discussion d'une de
censure donc la discussion elle devrait
avoir lieu ce week-end voir au-delà peu
de chance en revanche qu'elle
aboutissent parce que certes des voix LR
manque pour faire voter cette réforme
des retraites et c'est bien pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron a choisi de dégainer
l'article 49-3 mais ça ne signifie pas
que ces élus iraient jusqu'à franchir le
Rubicon en votant une motion de censure
d'ailleurs Éric Ciotti a dit aujourd'hui
que la droite ne vautrait aucune émotion
de censure on va voir si ces troupes
l'écoute effectivement autre arme de
l'opposition vient d'en parler le
recours les recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel et oui 60 députés 60
sénateurs peuvent saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel dans le viseur des
points précis du projet de loi par
exemple l'index senior qui pourrait être
considéré comme un cavalier social une
disposition qui n'a rien à faire dans ce
texte budgétaire mais l'opposition vous
l'avez dit conteste surtout l'ensemble
des conditions du débat c'est ce que
disait hier la sénatrice socialiste
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie sur ce
plateau on l'écoute
nous nous saisirons le Conseil
constitutionnel mais à chaque étape il
nous a semblé et il nous semble que la
clarté la sincérité du débat
parlementaire est en cause et donc est
un motif de censure voilà la position de
l'opposition c'est que le débat a été
tronqué tant de débat contraints par
l'article 47-1 manoeuvre pour faire
tomber 1000 amendements de la gauche sur
l'article 7 article 38 pour limiter le
temps de parole de l'opposition article
42 recouvre votre bloqué maintenant
article 49-3 et j'en passe alors donc ça
c'était pour les recours au niveau du
droit mais l'opposition les oppositions
veulent aussi en appeler au peuple et
oui c'est d'ailleurs ce que réclame
l'Inter syndical et cela depuis
maintenant plusieurs jours écoutez
en août il faut réfléchir à aller vers
une consultation des citoyens si le
président de la République continue de
considérer que les organisations
syndicales qui représentent des millions
de travailleurs qui manifestent n'en
sont même pas dignes d'être surpris
aujourd'hui puisque puisqu'il est ici
sur de l'huile président de la
République et bien il a consulté le
peuple et on verra la réponse du peuple
voilà l'opposition de gauche prépare un
référendum d'initiative par terre elle a
affirmé avoir les signatures des
parlementaires nécessaires il faut un
cinquième des membres du Parlement soit
au moins 185 signatures 185
parlementaires qui soutiennent une
proposition de loi qui annule la réforme
des retraites et empêche de partir à la
retraite au-delà de 62 ans mais le rip
est une procédure complexe à une
nécessite aussi d'être soutenue par un
dixième des électeurs soit 4,8 millions
de personnes alors seulement le texte
sera débattu par le Parlement si ce
n'est pas le cas Emmanuel Macron sera
tenu d'organiser un référendum cela
n'est jamais arrivé jusqu'ici puisque
l'unique tentative de RIP le rip sur
Aéroport de Paris en 2019 n'avait
rassemblé qu'un peu plus d'un million de
Français merci beaucoup Tom je me tourne
vers le spécialiste de l'opinion c'est 4
millions 800 000 personnes alors
évidemment c'est un texte dont on parle
beaucoup plus Aéroport de Paris c'était
voilà on peut dire plus plus limité même
géographiquement par définition ça
semble compliqué quand même c'est avant
tout un problème logistique parce que
trouver 4 millions de personnes qui sont
disposées à faire chuter le gouvernement
oui ça existe ils sont même bien plus
nombreux après voilà c'est quel est
quels sont les moyens la mise à
disposition par les formations
politiques pour y arriver ça va être
autrement plus compliqué des questions
de de de finances ça coûte cher de
mobiliser des gens et il faut avoir des
équipes pour le faire c'est franchement
pas évident mais après s'il devait y
avoir un référendum vous imaginez on
pourrait être assez assez confiant sur
le résultat et ça sera assez vite
Macron de toute façon c'est toujours
qu'on répond pas exactement à la
question du référendum quoi qu'il se
passe même si cette idée cette tent ça
veut sortir dire que le chemin de croix
du gouvernement s'est pas terminé même
si les il n'y a pas de censure du
gouvernement même si les oppositions
fracturées échouent à faire chuter le
gouvernement d'Elisabeth borne on le
voit bien je parlais tout à l'heure
d'absence de résignation ne sont pas
résignés les Français et donc et
l'opposé les opposition et les
organisations syndicales trouvent de
nouveaux moyens de non pas de gagner du
temps mais de continuer à parler de ça
et de d'entretenir non pas cette musique
mais d'entretenir ce mouvement de
contestation qui je le rappelle n'a
jamais faibli à aucun moment depuis
trois mois si il y a quand même un peu
moins de monde dans les manifestations
les deux dernières années ce qu'on peut
comprendre d'ailleurs
financière évidemment mais
manifester je le redis quand vous avez
des Français qui se disent ce n'est pas
grave si les trains sont bloqués ce
n'est pas grave si les ordures managers
ne sont pas ramassés ce n'est pas grave
si les raffinés sont bloqués c'est bien
que l'on qu'on a décidé de faire payer
au gouvernement ça son passage en force
sa brutalité est-ce que je suis
passionnant dans ce que vous nous
décrivez uncharid biniza c'est c'est
finalement le la question du temps la
temporalité c'est à dire que le recours
devant le constituel tant que tant qu'il
est pas
fois que ça a pas été voilà acté tant
que le Conseil constitutionnel va donner
sa décision pour celles et ceux qui
manifestent qui organisent ces
manifestations c'est une justification
de continuer d'être présent et de faire
pression oui ce qui est vraiment
intéressant dans ce processus législatif
et constitutionnel c'est qu'on voit bien
que la bataille parlementaire n'est
finalement qu'un temps de de cette
contestation alors qu'on a le sentiment
quel cristallise l'avenir du texte et
bien non voilà toutes les armes
constitutionnelles et politiques
possibles pour mettre ce texte en
difficulté ce gouvernement en difficulté
sont aujourd'hui utilisés et on voit
bien d'ailleurs et je pense que ça
rejoint le mot l'idée du mouvement
social un mouvement social n'est pas
forcément corrélé non plus d'ailleurs à
ce temps parlementaire une loi votée
n'est pas au sens en tout cas où la
contestation sociale l'entend une loi
appliquée on a tous en mémoire la
susmulation c'est le terme de
guitarcason du CPE
c'était ça la petite blague mais en soi
bon voilà on se doute bien que que
toutes les oppositions feront tout bois
je douche un petit peu les espoirs du
groupe parlementaire socialiste sur sa
saisine du Conseil conditionnel à propos
de du principe de clarté et de sincérité
c'est vrai qu'on a on a eu on a dit
l'accumulation de tous les mécanismes du
parlementarisme rationalisé mais je vois
ajouter que chacun d'entre eux a été
utilisé suivant les formes
constitutionnelles et donc on voit mal
comment le Conseil consuel censuré
peut-être l'intégralité de la procédure
parlementaire à moins de jouer pour le
coup un coup non seulement juridique
mais très politique allez je vous
propose un focus sur le présent de la
République Emmanuel Macron et on
commence avec vous Mathilde Macron y
a-t-il vraiment cru alors ça a pu
paraître illisible Thomas parce que
c'est vrai que jusqu'à hier encore on
nous disait la dynamique en faveur du
vote est positive Elizabeth borne qui
répètait mardi à l'Assemblée il existe
une majorité pour cette loi et puis et
puis finalement ce 49-3 déclenché à la
dernière minute alors on connaît le goût
du président pour décider à la dernière
minute vraiment au tout dernier moment
on l'avait vu pendant le la pandémie sur
les histoires de d'ouverture des écoles
ou de confinement de couvre-feu à chaque
fois c'était au tout dernier moment
qu'il tranchait là évidemment c'est
encore le cas puisque jusqu'à ce matin
d'écouter téléphone ont été passés
ils se sont retrouvés à la mi-journée à
l'Élysée et Aurore berger comme Franck
Riester ont rapporté des comptages
différents au président sur les votes
DLR les deux présentaient cependant un
résultat plutôt risqué pour le vote donc
ils se sont retrouvés ensuite pour une
nouvelle réunion à 14h et ministre et
député était incapables de dire Emmanuel
Macron si le nombre de voix pour était
suffisant ou pas pour que la réforme
passe à ce moment-là le président a donc
tranché après un ultime tour de table
qui pense qu'il faut aller au vote le
Président il a posé la question à ceux
qui étaient autour de lui et personne
vraiment ne se risquait à pousser à ce
moment-là en faveur du du vote donc il a
fallu trancher en faveur du 49-3 avec
les arguments qu'on a vu que
financièrement budgétairement la France
ne pouvait pas il y a quand même eu une
mise en scène autour de ce suspense
évidemment il y a eu donc derrière le
théâtre et ses déclarations de ces
derniers jours une sorte de dramaturgie
politique qui sait jouer l'exécutif a
cherché dans cette communication à
prendre en quelques sortes l'opinion à
partir en montrant sa bonne volonté en
se montrant ouvert en disant avoir
redoublé d'efforts à porter des
concessions pour espérer à la fin faire
porter le mystique de la responsabilité
du 49-3 au Républicain ce qui paraît
quand même un peu hasardeuse conclusion
de cette de toute cette séquence par un
proche du chef de l'État qui nous dit
Elisabeth Elisabeth borne se retrouve
dans la position d'Emmanuel Macron avec
Valls en 2015 on se souvient parce que à
l'époque Emmanuel Macron avait dit
disposer de 5 voix d'avance pour sa loi
Macron et finalement Manuel Valls avait
imposé 149-3 sauf que nuance ce proche
du président Elisabeth borne a beaucoup
moins de vent dans le dos qui Emmanuel
Macron à cette époque est-ce qu'il y a
une hypocrisie de l'exécutif franchement
non ce qui est certain c'est que
beaucoup d'acteurs n'avaient pas intérêt
à ce qu'il y a un vote classique et
quand je dis beaucoup d'acteurs c'est
des acteurs parlementaires un certain
nombre de parlementaires LR préfère sans
doute qu'il y a un 49-3 plutôt que il
soit obligé de sortir de l'ambiguïté
vous savez on connaît la date on ne sort
de l'ambiguïté qu'à son propre détriment
et donc dans un certain nombre de cas un
vote classique aurait obligé certains
d'entre eux qui sont dans la frange un
peu hésitante à s'afficher d'un côté ou
de l'autre l'avantage qui voulait pas
dire bien sûr s'ils étaient pour ou
contre l'avantage d'où les comptages un
certain quoi exactement il y en a même
qui se sont qui ont déclaré ce qu'ils
allaient faire en indiquant par exemple
qu'ils allaient s'abstenir aujourd'hui
même un très tardivement et donc
l'avantage pour cette frange de
parlementaire du 49-3 bah c'est que là
le choix il est plus simple parce que là
on est plus on a plus à se prononcer
d'une certaine manière sur la pertinence
ou la non pertinence du projet de
réforme on a se prononcer sur le fait de
vouloir renverser le gouvernement ou pas
mais mais
erikiotti a beau avoir dit d'ailleurs
Tam l'évoquais que le groupe LR ne
voterait pas l'émotion de censure il y a
tout de suite après certains députés qui
c'est vrai mais ceux qui vont voter la
motion de censure pour le coup c'est
ceux qui étaient plutôt ils se rangent
plutôt parmi ceux qui avaient annoncé
d'ores et déjà qui voteraient contre
donc il y a pas tellement de surprises
dans de c'est plutôt sur la frange qui
était un peu hésitante qui était un peu
incertaine qui parfois envoyé des
signaux et parfois quand il retournait
dans leur circonscriptions se faisait
remonter les bretelles entre guillemets
par leurs concitoyens et donc ce disait
voilà et donc effectivement le
gouvernement a organisé vous l'avez dit
une forme de dramaturgie jusqu'au bout
et une forme d'hésitation sincère
jusqu'au bout à travers les pointages et
à travers le souhait qui aurait été
celui du gouvernement je pense que le
gouvernement aurait préféré en passer
par un vote classique et
usé de cette dramaturgie justement pour
essayer de peser sur ses hésitants en
leur disant certes vous préférez pot
également on voit bien que vous préférez
49-3 mais si on entretient cette forme
de suspense c'est parce que on veut vous
faire passer le message que il y a une
possibilité non négligeable qu'on en
passe par un vote classique alors la
question centrale de notre débat on y
répond par plein de billets différents
c'est le gouvernement peut risque-t-il
d'être renversé un Charlène bizida va y
avoir plusieurs motions de censure et
puis avoir une coalition des oppositions
alors il la faut pour que la motion de
censure aboutisse puisque c'est le
principe de notre cinquième République
on a là aussi rationalisé l'usage de
cette notion de censure dans le sens où
seuls les votes favorables à cette
motion seront décomptés donc l'abstance
gepicine etc comme on a bien vu que
c'était un peu à la mode en ce moment ne
contrat évidemment pas donc il faut se
compter dans les contre cette fois-ci on
a passé la semaine à se compter dans les
pour donc maintenant on va on va devoir
faire la calculette inverse et dans les
contres d'après mon calcul je crois
qu'on est à peu près autour de 257 258
si on additionne l'héliottes les RN
l'intégralité des parties de gauche et
on voit bien qu'il va manquer forcément
nécessairement un soutien LR et c'est
pour ça que on parle de coalition pour
arriver à la motion de censure il faut
savoir quand même que sous la Cinquième
République on a abouti une seule fois à
une notion de censure une motion de
censure qui en plus n'était même pas
suite à un 49-3 mais qui était une
motion censure
osée et puis pour le coup parce qu'elle
était provoqué par l'Assemblée nationale
elle-même et c'est cette motion de
censure qui donne le précédent à
Emmanuel Macron de de d'avoir ensuite
conduit à la dissolution donc la motion
de censure elle est elle est elle est
larme par laquelle l'Assemblée nationale
se défend finalement de l'offense qu'on
lui fait de dégainer un débat sans vote
mais c'est rare qu'elle aboutisse encore
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on est au moins
à s'il est LR apparaissent encore en
ordre dispersé au moins à 10 à 15 voix
quand même de de calage et on l'a déjà
un peu évoqué mais je voudrais bien vous
entendre de nouveau là dessus Stéphane
zumsec il y a quand même ce constat de
faiblesse pour pour les dirigeants à
l'air enfin en tout cas ceux de ceux de
l'Assemblée nationale avec l'humiliation
pas d'Olivier malex le président du
groupe mais enfin aucun moment
renouveler là avec la motion
la grande incertitude on supposant
qu'une censure soit possible c'est que
vont faire les frondeurs si on les
appelle comme ça c'est 20-25 députés LR
hésitant il y a quand même un élément il
faut avoir en tête c'est le profil de
ces gens-là les plus exactement le
profil de leur circonscription la
plupart de cesondeurs pas tous mais la
plupart ils ont été élu dans des
circonscriptions souvent du grand test
de la France dans le circonscription
rurales et face au rassemblement
national ils ont comme principal ennemis
dans leur ou adversaire en tout cas dans
une logique de second tour des candidats
RN et on a vu à quel point le RN avait
progressé l'année dernière donc ces
gens-là quand même faut se mettre à leur
place si aux prochaines élections ils
auront face à eux un RN puissant
forcément qui pourrait encore progresser
voter l'ascension du gouvernement c'est
quand même rap envoyer un message à ses
électeurs si jamais il y a une
dissolution personne n'a envie de se
remettre à une campagne électorale mais
si il devait en passer par là il serait
là on est attendez ne dites pas que je
suis un traître j'ai tout fait pour
faire tomber le
le gouvernement je me je me préoccupe de
considération sociale ne votez pas ARN
il va nécessaire de voter RN le candidat
des des classes populaires le défenseur
de classe populaire c'est moi c'est moi
le sortant LR j'ajoute une dernière
chose ces gens-là ont été élus ils ont
la plupart du temps élu ou élu ce sont
des trentenaires il considèrent que ils
doivent à leur propre équation
personnelle le fait d'avoir gagné et
absolument pas à l'étiquette LR qui est
évidemment n'était pas un avantage lors
des dernières législatives donc ça aussi
tout ça entretient quand même malgré
tout une petite incertitude il faut
savoir que Aurélien Pradier a fait
savoir dès ce soir qu'il ne
s'interdisait pas de voter une d'émotion
alors on va écouter un autre extrait du
discours de de d'Élisabeth borne quand
elle cible justement cette fois-ci le
rassemblement national
sur le mutisme de ceux à l'extrême
droite de cette émission qui sont restés
de l'ombre tout au long des débats
préférée se taire profitons en silence
des outrances des uns et des revirements
des autres franchement elle devrait
rester sur le rassemblement national qui
va peut-être finalement
être le parti qui profite le plus de
cette de cette séquence politique parce
que la réforme si elle aboutit elle
rentre en vigueur en septembre ensuite
elle s'applique année après année
progressivement pour plusieurs classes
d'âge qui vont se retrouver à voter en
2027 vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est une réforme avec une une rémanence
ça va rester dans la mémoire des
électeurs pendant longtemps non ce qui
est toujours le cas des réformes des
retraites oui d'une manière générale on
a on n'a jamais vu de réformes des
retraites qui s'appliquent le lendemain
matin on a toujours un échelonnement
dans le temps ce qui est bien normal
bien sûr l'impact politique alors
l'impact politique évidemment vous
l'avez décrit vis-à-vis durant
faiblement national d'ailleurs Marine Le
Pen a eu une stratégie extrêmement
différente de la stratégie de rupture on
va dire pour prendre une image qui est
celle de l'avocat on a parfois la
stratégie de défense de rupture c'est
qui était la stratégie de la nuque la
stratégie du RN n'était pas du tout la
stratégie de rupture elle est plutôt la
stratégie du profil bas et du fait
d'engranger benoîtement tranquillement
un certain nombre de choses ce qui se
produit plutôt pour l'instant alors il
va falloir voir ça dans le temps voir si
dans le temps effectivement le RN arrive
à continuer à capitaliser là-dessus
Marine Le Pen a été la seule pour
l'heure à annoncer que si elle arrivait
un jour au pouvoir elle reviendrait sur
la réforme je pense que ça sera un grand
objet de débat lors des prochaines
échéances électorales de savoir comment
se positionne les uns et les autres et
je l'ai déjà dit moi je prends le pari
que quel que soit le résultat d'élection
on ne reviendra pas d'une manière ou
d'une autre quoi que les uns et les
autres disent sur la réforme parce
qu'effectivement en termes d'équation
financière ça serait quelque chose
d'assez compliqué mais soit dit en
passant en tout cas ça va être un objet
débat ça va être un objet de débat et le
RN a été le premier à dégainer à
dégainer sur le sujet bien évidemment
dernier thème tiens on va prolonger un
tout petit peu ce premier débat on va on
va parler des des suites sociales
puisqu'il y a des manifestations un peu
improvisées qui se sont
organisés alors à Paris mais aussi dans
plusieurs villes de France Grenoble
Toulouse Lyon gencive quelques-unes à
Paris c'était sur la place de la
Concorde symboliquement évidemment tout
près de l'Assemblée nationale c'est de
l'autre côté de la de la scène et elle a
permis à Jean-Luc Mélenchon de venir
battre le pavé on l'écoute
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
importance significative emblématique
que il est fallu cet article 5 de cet
article 43 pour la cinquième fois pour
passer par de la volonté du peuple et
bien maintenant voilà il faut qu'on soit
dans l'action avec les syndicats et que
tout soit fait qui permet que la loi
soit retirée car chaque jour qui passe
pour ma part ma confiance dans l'idée
qu'elle ne soit pas maintenue augmente
et je crois que comme moi beaucoup de
gens le ressentiment alors bon on va pas
revenir sur la difficulté pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon d'être en phase avec les
principaux leaders syndicaux je l'ai
déjà évoqué dans dans ce débat mais
peut-être uncharlen bizina pour un
Laurent Berger par exemple c'est
intéressant parce que le 49-3 ça lui
facilite la tâche il peut rester dans
une opposition frontale à la réforme là
on est dans une capitalisation pour
l'intersydical qui est absolue c'est la
c'est la vérité il l'avait fait savoir
d'ailleurs au préalable que sous 49-3
que ça soit d'ailleurs Laurent Berger ou
ou le président de la CGT donc voilà
Philippe Martinez elle l'avait fait tous
les deux ce 49-3 aura une texture
sociale qui n'a vraiment jamais eu de
tout son existence oui ça fait les
silitent les choses et puis encore une
fois on l'a dit l'idée de passer encore
par une méthode autoritaire va renforcer
finalement la le le ressac populaire de
tout se ressentiment autour de la
réforme donc je crois en effet que là
même si il y a eu essoufflement alors ce
qui pèse en tout cas sur cet interdire
syndicale c'est le temps c'est à dire
que on l'a dit économiquement ça n'est
pas neutre de faire la grève de d'être
dans un blocage économique donc est-ce
que ça peut continuer sur le temps en
tout cas oui c'est à nouveau de
l'essence dans le moteur un dernier mot
peut-être Stéphane je sais que sur le
sur la capacité d'Emmanuel Macron
finalement à continuer à réformer parce
que c'est blanc mais c'est sans doute là
on est en train de faire un double
constat côté politique
sont pas des partenaires fiables et puis
côté syndical on a cru comprendre que il
serait pas prêt enfin ils vont peut-être
venir à des tables de négociation sur
d'autres projets mais ce sera ce sera
compliqué quoi en fait dans la courte
histoire de la macronie la réussi à
rebondir une fois pour l'instant ce
n'est à la sortie des gilets jaunes avec
la concertation il a été élu dans les
conditions pensées assez brillamment là
compte tenu de cette opposition contenu
de des reproches qui lui sont
directement adressées je reviens sur ce
terme de brutalité qui est central de
toute façon quelque soit l'issue de
cette bataille parlementaire de toute
façon pour les mois et probablement pour
les années pour les 4 ans qui restent ça
relation avec l'opinion sera très sera
très compliqué et je pense que la
relation est abîmée et il y a une vraie
incompréhension je pense que les
Français y compris les Français qui ont
voté pour lui non pas au premier tome
mais au second tour qui ont permis quand
même de gagner avec 17 points d'avance
qui n'est pas rien face à Marine Le Pen
ces gens-là qui se sont forcés à voter
pour Emmanuel Macron pour toutes les
raisons qu'on pense ne comprennent pas
ne le comprennent véritablement pas et
c'est steam totalement trahi floué en
fait il y a eu erreur sur la marchandise
il y a eu mensonge sur la marchandise
c'est un petit peu ça le bilan et je
vois mal comment il pourrait récupérer
de la sympathie de la bienveillance il
faut apprendre c'était déjà le cas sous
Hollande et sous Sarkozy il faut
apprendre à gouverner quand et quand on
est soutenu par 30% des des Français par
un petit tiers des Français c'est très
peu et donc ça ne met pas à l'abri un
exécutif un gouvernement et un président
d'échec ou de chemin de croix
parlementaire mais c'est je pense que
c'est la conséquence de la fragmentation
de l'offre politique il y a plus de
bipolarisation c'est pas la gauche
contre la droite il y a des oppositions
partout vous ne pouvez avoir que même si
vous avez 250 députés c'est beaucoup
dernier mot vous n'avez que 1/3 des
Français qui soutiennent votre action
c'est très peu et au moindre accident de
parcours vous êtes dans une situation
politique très périlleuse un défi pour
Emmanuel Macron qui ne sera passionnant
de commenter sur ce plateau merci à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat